[Music]  any shot that I can convince you to do a  little prank call like with the - with  one of your kids right now  we could try Chloe hi boo what do you do  bunny listen I have a really quick  question they asked me to do playboy  well they said that I didn't have to  show anything so is that a no it's your  life I support you support us I I don't  know they're telling me it is you're  like the hottest mom I've ever seen  Chloe I love you so much  this was a prank call and I'm on  Entertainment Tonight and this is wild  that you were so nice to me this ha ha  ha say hi to Cameron hey Chloe hi I love  you Chloe  see what I mean so good kids they're  good kids they're nice to their mama  [Music]